I mean it's just a movie news submitted
by doorbuster deals Westinghouse
television $115 what's the house is like
the shittiest brand you could imagine
having talked about doorbuster deal
that's an expression yeah they're like
all trying to like kind of American art
you don't know I bet you come on a door
what that's actually I could see I can
see it tends to mention houses that's
true I don't even know about this TV
that this set is deceptively small but
it weighs more than it looks yeah you
know I'm singing what's insignia yeah
exactly it's basically another brand
it's another bargain brand for TVs yeah
I think I have a Sony somebody's
watching this right now and an insignia
and they're going all this peasant talk
I don't get a TCL it's a good friend
they're giving those away
y'all just making [ __ ] up now man it's
real Ally no Sony and Samsung TCL don't
go change
oh actually crazy rich Asian oh we did
well in the u.s. beers is apparently a
flop in China because they're like
you're not as rich as me oh yeah yeah so
like you're not that rich movie bought
poor people what the hell this is from
Wall Street Journal this one sentence
made me laugh my ass off are you ready
in China home to the world's largest
population of Asians it is bombing right
nationwide tickets it ticket sales have
barely top 1.4 million so far what it's
an Asian it's an Asian American film so
it's not relatable over there either
right yeah
big fella probably feels very false and
disingenuous but David it's it says
Asian well know it that makes sense
right at least curious about like our
content over here but they watch the
[ __ ] out of Americans say what Americans
yeah black people my people I mean it
was it was hyped up here because we've
never seen a movie with a full Asian
cast right over there it's like like
it's it's imagine if a movie came out
out here that was called like you know
like like white people doing white
people [ __ ] it's like we've seen this
for the past hundred years what are we
watching a documentary or why white man
[ __ ] up i we watched that movie seven
times now we want agent guy [ __ ] a
sushi tape nobody's although that's
arrived it wouldn't make us all that
comes hero Dreams of Sushi oh that was
good zero wet dreams of sushi yeah man
meanwhile [ __ ] skyscraper Padma is
ten billion dollars in China love
skyscraper oh yeah well because yet when
that makes sense too because they don't
have a lot of like guys class you know
Islander black dudes [ __ ] jumping off
a building this [ __ ] and now he's on is
called the Bison compared to this anyway
I don't know that they love skyscraper
I'm saying compared to 1.4 million yeah
you better believe skyscraper a one
point four million tickets or dollar
0.49 oh yeah theatres that's like one
theater in China say empty theatres are
forced cinemas to cancel thousands of
planned screenings Wow one online
reviewer compared to the movie to
General Tso's chicken Rotten Tomatoes oh
my god there's a [ __ ] comment what's
a giant what the Chinese equivalent to a
tomato rotten personally yeah
wait so we have Tomatoes too [ __ ]
Chinese perspective on this like is
there anyone that's like well we don't
want to see something that we already do
you didn't say anything that Frank it
was very much like um cuz when I saw
this I didn't think Asian American I
thought Singaporean culture which is
totally different from like Chinese yes
Singaporean Chinese is different from
China China yeah any [ __ ] country
that likes Chronicles of Riddick should
not have an opinion of Vin Diesel so and
who can blame them they talked to this
student named a Hewlett now okay he went
to catch the movie right cuz he heard
about how American love it and he said
there's half a dozen people in the field
in the theater at all and the film left
him feeling perplexed he said it was
very light-hearted but he didn't like
how it portrayed wealthy Chinese people
as quote having old-fashioned thoughts
and behaviors that are in poor taste oh
okay here's the thing okay I watch this
documentary about mainland Chinese
moving to Vancouver right there's a lot
of people moving there yeah but here's
the thing the Chinatown there and the
old kung fu schools and the restaurants
novels they're dying out because there's
a disconnect from mainland Chinese and
the old-school Chinese because
culturally they can't vibe so after
communism and all that should happen
they threw away all of Confucianism and
all those ways of thinking and they are
like let's let's think about the future
let's think about like let's be more you
know different I guess you know so
there's a lot of things where they look
at old Chinese culture or whatever and
go oh that's so outdated dangerous or
they might be looking at this movie
exactly as that cuz oh it makes sense
yeah so it wasn't crazy chastens and
they're like no one thinks like this
anymore there's like no one can relate
to this old grandmas make you find an
old [ __ ] yeah look at them it's much
more this is what I was talking about
like even in my comments like they don't
understand they're only seeing if
through their perspective right yeah so
you can't tell an asian-american what
their asian-american experience is just
like I can't tell you what your Chinese
we're only saying through our lens but I
know for what we expect for people here
yeah
and we're dumb to high quality consumers
it's a new you know it's very new like
their middle classes new all that stuff
so like art is a luxury of people with
money yeah like you you know it over
time when the when the rich is like old
money and middle classes like there for
a long time I think they're gonna
cultivate a better taste but for the
[ __ ] movies and [ __ ] crazy which is
such a specific story
you don't say yeah very mish yeah
because like Singapore Singapore is on
BAM you go to Singapore it's like like
fantasy world you feel me like well the
part that's horse goes to anyways right
there with you in Singapore yeah that's
right right and it's it's so like you go
there it's like you you feel like you're
on another planet officer mean this
place I've ever been dude it's like
freshly cleaned the streets are [ __ ]
clean there's no gum anywhere cuz it's
illegal that's all just the touristy the
whole I mean do and every crack a
Singapore is beautiful and pristine so
there's this critique from from real
people that live in Singapore saying
like not all Singapore is dis like rich
people's [ __ ] right but at the same time
there's still like gum is still illegal
everywhere still mad clean and then they
don't even let locals into the casino
they have like these casinos at the top
of these buildings oh [ __ ] and they
don't let locals go there because they
don't want locals to be in the gambling
they only have them for like Westerners
who come Oh genius no Singapore like
crazy man like yo it's one of my
favourite countries a visit cuz it's
it's different and bro like especially
if you've never been to I always tell
people that have never been to an Asian
country to go to Singapore first because
it's almost like a like a stepping stone
yeah it's nothing so because everyone
speaks English like because that's
Singapore's first language because it's
so diverse out there everyone just kind
of goes to Singapore just uh need a
colony
yeah so it was Malaysia at one point and
then the Chinese people were
second-class citizens in Malaysia but
they were ballin
so that area the mayor of that town just
said ku yeah we're gonna have we're
gonna come over it's a direct quote
anything and he pees and he's like we
are now
little China it was a great speech if to
look it up oh it's weird there's like
Louie boots on stores like every two
blocks yeah it's like you're in Beverly
Hills it was crazy but it's dope yeah
it's crazy rich Asians did how much here
that they don't [ __ ] to here's a lot and
they still here grossing rom-com of like
[ __ ] like that
no they surpassed like some some big-ass
shoes there's a passage at Judd Apatow
movies and [ __ ] yeah dude I don't know
it did really well here and in in a time
where like the movie industry is kind of
struggling and people aren't going to
movies like them getting that kind of
success is [ __ ] amazing especially
for you know especially for in holidays
in cast and that didn't really have like
a list celebrities you know saying I was
pleasantly surprised by how well that
should did like okay look I was gonna I
was gonna say the movie was the [ __ ]
regardless just because I want people to
go see Asian movies but it wasn't it was
cute it was it was like I was a solid
movie that's super cute yeah I was I was
like having fun the whole time
mm-hmm so I mean that's probably what
people want like they just want like
light-hearted fun so Chinese people
don't know know how to have fun I don't
think they know how to it made me smile
well that's what this with this other
lady she said that it quote it
reinforced the stereotype that Chinese
people are now are rich and all they do
is buy a bye bye I mean she is a she is
a 33 year old financial professional in
Shanghai so I'm like you're not in this
conversation said a very wealthy woman
yeah I didn't think it was gonna do well
in China honestly yeah like it's such a
yeah I thought it would do well for like
Asians that live in english-speaking
countries all of our trash films here do
really well overseas yeah yeah I think
the gratuitous explosions very like
transformers do that thing [ __ ]
yeah he doesn't need a lot of backstory
it just need hi pack action and great
like effects yeah because we have in
America we had the best CG animation
it's amazing here any natural disaster
movie will kill it in every card quick
volcano tsunami any and they kill it in
America yeah I've said so many like
Japanese Chinese and Korean from the dis
see G yo CG is terrible it looks like
the stuff that I could do one after
effect think about all that all that
[ __ ] like an Independence Day right we
were all jerking off going to the movie
theater yeah because we're like the
[ __ ] White House is so sick but then
now it's like Diplo the White House is
so sick of people like hey it's like
dude that used to be the [ __ ] chant
yeah you know a movie I thought was dope
when I was a kid and I watched it now
I'm like ah they should remake this is a
moral combat oh ok first of all I
watched Street Fighter I was like oh she
fighters amazing and then more comic and
I was like oh she fighters back I kiss
more comment with so much better bring
it better i watch more combat and quebec
now I'm like yo this is so like corny
like the effects are so bad like I want
them to remake it cuz like it would be
crazy now you remember surf ninjas oh
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] dude old man did
something clear stunt double would come
in closer than the kid on the gamegear
and he's like well I'm again we have
controlling everything yeah if that was
happening to me I would never be like oh
maybe my game gear is controlling real
life that's what's so great about kids
movies ninjas wow yeah and then three
ninjas of course a top-three rocky cult
and Tom Tom bro Alton tongue you are tum
top like you tell everything you look
fat but
there's that kid is like Brad Pitt and
Burn After Reading he who's eating
something in every scene
here's my favorite character right Brad
Pitt look probably like I'm gonna do a
TomTom in there so just gonna do it like
yeah sure sure sure
good colors like they reference tum tum
right
[Music]
[Music]